bonjour bonjour ça gueule ça va house
était déjà super chaud ici je me suis
payé trois fois déjà ce n'est fait un
truc de fou j'ai croisé top cool au
petit déj il est un petit peu stressé
quand même un ton tout à l'heure que
vous ayez fait pas le malin puis pour
marquer l'arrivée en fanfare de la suite
de top gun sur la croisette quoi de
mieux que la patrouille de france nos
top gun à nous ont fait décoller l'avion
ayant survolé le palais des festivals
avant la projection du film hors
compétition dans la grande salle lumière
merci
c'est vraiment très spécial d'être ici
et en plus ya pas de basse donc j'adore
j'adore
vient d'interviewer ton
question d'elodie quéré notre rédactrice
en chef elle me l'a soufflé à
l'oreillette est ce qu'il sent bon temps
cruz sérieux je sais j'ai un peu près
comme moi c'est vous dire à l'accent
très bon alors voilà et il a les mains
douces
pierre il a les mains extrêmement doux
il a une voix très aiguë
oui c'est vrai bon alors je vais pas
ajouter quelque chose d'extraordinaire
vous êtes ensemble à la vie comme à
l'écran d'ailleurs mais il paraît que
vous avez dû vous battre pour avoir le
rôle me battre c'est un grand mot mais
j'étais pas prévu au début ouais je
n'étais pas prévu j'étais trop jolie
qu'elle était trop jolie n'ont jamais je
réussis
d'abord parce qu'il n'est pas si jolie
nouaillé et ça commence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais qu'est ce qui se passe rien tout va
bien ah bon je m'attendais pas du tout à
ça ado est ce que tu as un slip tu veux
voir
[Applaudissements]
instant tapis rouge le point moquette
paca qui vous est présentée par la dame
qui n'est pas du tout content d'être à
cannes
[Musique]
on peut sortir et revenir et ce plateau
s'il vous plaît on sait pas toujours
parce magnéto
allô allô
allô inquiéter le franc direct ce sera
vraiment la mission dalo pouvez vous
nous avons besoin d'un nouveau chaplin
âmes qui prouvera une fois encore que le
cinéma n'est pas muet itx et l'aude et
des gens meurent tous les jours en
ukraine
ils ne vont pas se relever après le clap
de fin signate et achètent des cta il ya
un dictateur et libère pour la liberté
ex tout dépendra de notre unité le
cinéma peut-il rester en dehors de cette
unité qu'ils n'ont positif émis
gerritsen j'ai perdu deux nuls à tamalé
top 14 mais comme on l'a vu le 15
avant de préparer un goûter tout cas
autour de 14
d'accord mais n'hésitez pas à me
répondre surtout ya pris personne ne
sait où les mois ce qui m'embête c'est
que vous voyez bien effectivement que ça
heurte une majorité de nos concitoyens y
compris des musulmans je leur répète
enfin d'accord ça choquait valeur
beaucoup de gens mais daniel sedin il ya
des tonnes de pays où on s'est
encouragées
je veux dire la france est effectivement
ce pays singulier moi je pense que ce
que vous avez en échange c'est une
merveille à une autre info rigolote
autour de ce nouveau top gun on quitte
l'hélicoptère pour l'avion à l'écran
vous allez voir un engin hypersonique il
sort du film c'est un faux ce n'est pas
un vrai avion militaire il a juste été
conçu pour top gun est une maquette de
faux avion hypersonique militaire et
cette indiscrétion de tournage le
producteur du film relais des
informations de l'armée américaine
encore eu un satellite chinois a changé
de direction afin de photographier
l'avion il pensait qu'il était réel
évidemment à 100 peut citer ces c'est
souvent simples l'émotion c'est souvent
semble pas en passe en piste ils sont
sains le mec high level
et enchaîner avec un meeting hier soir
saint nazaire pour faire la promotion
des candidats de lannux enfin la nuque
baisse enfin je sais plus comment il
faut dire le plus simple c'est de
laisser la parole à jean luc mélenchon
il y aura un bulletin au nom du candidat
ou de la candidate de la nouvelle union
populaire et communiquent à je ne sais
plus qu'à trouver un truc pareil
écologique et sociale ras pour deux
heures à le dire battus au mans l'a
compris le système énergétique mondial
est en panne et nous rapproche de plus
en plus d'une catastrophe
environnementale
les combustibles fossiles sont une
impasse tant sur le plan environnemental
qu'économique lier en ukraine et ses
effets immédiats sur les prix de
l'énergie sont un autre signal d'alarmé
le seul avenir durable est un avenir
renouvelable nous devons mettre fin à la
pollution par les combustibles fossiles
et accélérer la transition vers les
énergies renouvelables avant d'incinérer
notre seule maison